[Music]
heyyyyyy everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing a
terrible place where all of the worst
witches and wizards in Wizarding World
assent to repent for their crimes I am
of course talking about Azkaban an
island fortress that has existed since
the 15th century the name Azkaban is a
mixture of the word Alcatraz which
refers to a famous muggle Island prison
and Abaddon which is a Hebrew word that
means place of destruction sounds
wonderful doesn't it at one point in
time before the fortress was built
Azkaban was just an island but when it's
first inhabitant the Christus found the
island he decided to transform it into
his own little dark arts experiment the
Christus was a Dark Wizard that
practiced the worst forms of dark magic
and he was known to lure sailors to the
island then tortured them before he got
there he was crazy but after spending
considerable amount of time there he
went completely bonkers
while the Christus lived there he placed
concealment charms on the island so that
no one would be able to find it and
after he died his concealment charms
were finally lifted this is when the
British Ministry of Magic first
discovered the island the investigative
team from the ministry who first went to
Azkaban refused to discuss their
findings other than the fact that the
island was infested with the mentis I
don't think we want to know what sort of
things happen there over the course of
its history Azkaban has been the home to
many witches and wizards including
Percival Dumbledore Bart amis Crouch jr.
various lestranges various Gaunt's and
many more just to name a few though it
was under much scrutiny initially when
the ministry recognized they could
utilize the island to imprison evildoers
they capitalized on this and began
sentencing people to Azkaban the
Ministry of Magic felt that the smaller
existing Wizarding prisons that were
scattered across the country posed a
considerable security risk and put
citizens in danger
makes sense Azkaban serves as the
ultimate prison due to its remote
location and the sea of Dementors that
make sure the prisoners are in check
escaping from Azkaban before your
sentences over is punishable by a fate
worse than death
a Dementors kiss the island itself is
located in the North Sea but the island
is said to have never appeared on any
map muggle or magical it's suspected
that the island was either created or
enlarged via magical means I'm thinking
that Chris dis was probably responsible
for that the North Sea is a marginal sea
of the Atlantic Ocean located between
Great Britain Denmark Norway Germany the
Netherlands Belgium and France what I
want to know is if it has never appeared
on any map and all we know is that it's
in the North Sea which is gigantic how
are we supposed to find it where is it
fortunately using context from the books
and films we actually are able to more
accurately pinpoint its exact location
let's start with chapter 1 of the
half-blood Prince the other minister in
this very first chapter of the book
Cornelius fudge gives us a bit of
context that can help us to begin to
locate the island I've just come from
Azkaban fudge had panted tipping a large
amount of water out at the rim of his
bowler hat into his pocket middle of the
North Sea you know nasty flight the
Dementors are an uproar he shuddered
they've never had a breakout before okay
so with that we can safely determine
that it's somewhere in the middle of the
North Sea this helps narrow it down a
little bit and it makes sense that it
would be right in the middle of the
ocean what's interesting about this
piece of text however is that we know
that Sirius Black escaped the island by
transforming into a dog and swimming to
the mainland the North Sea is 600 miles
by 360 miles did Sirius swim hundreds of
miles to shore in the extremely
turbulent waters depicted in the film
interesting brushing that aside in
chapter 19 of the Prisoner of Azkaban
the servant of Lord Voldemort Sirius
gives us a clue in the text
that can further help us to locate
Azkaban I swam as a dog back to the
mainland
I journeyed north and slipped into the
Hogwarts grounds as a dog I've been
living in the forest ever since except
when I come to watch the Quidditch of
course you fly as well as your father
did Harry what we can extrapolate from
this piece of text is that Azkaban
prison is located to the south of
Hogwarts as he had to journey north
after swimming back to the mainland
using this information and the knowledge
that Hogwarts is located somewhere in
northern Scotland we can hone in on
Azkaban a little bit closer while
pinpointing its exact location isn't
possible I think that we can safely
assume that Azkaban is located somewhere
off the coast of northern England or
southern Scotland Yorkshire
Northumberland Edinburgh we can also
deduce that Azkaban though central
within the North Sea is probably not
dead center as it's entirely implausible
that Sirius was able to swim hundreds of
miles in his dog form what do you guys
think are there any other clues which
would reveal the location of Azkaban
that I'm missing if so let me know down
in the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]